en este vídeo vamos a conectar los ojos
led de la araña y pueden ver que estas
lámparas leds tienen cuatro patas y una
de ellas es más larga que las demás
vamos a doblar hacia atrás la pata más
larga el primero que vamos a poner va a
tener esta patita más doblada hacia
atrás de manera que una de las patas se
conecte al pin 12 y las otras dos se
conecten a los siguientes dos lugares
disponibles que son los pines 7 y 8 por
lo que vamos a doblar y separar las
patas para que entren en estos lugares
la pata larga queda doblada hacia atrás
ahora hacemos lo mismo para el siguiente
led doblamos hacia atrás la pata más
larga y ahora conectaremos las otras
tres patas que van en los pines 4 3 y 2
lo hacemos con cuidado ya que puede
costarnos un poco de trabajo lograrlo
listo estos van a ser nuestros ojos los
alineamos bien
y ya que tenemos los leds en su lugar
podemos tomar nuestras resistencias y
conectarlas a nuestros leds las patas
que doblamos hacia atrás son nuestros
negativos son los que conectamos a la
parte negativa del circuito vamos a
cortar un poco los extremos de las
resistencias y de las patas de los leds
y lo recortamos un poco ya que no ocupan
demasiado espacio después vamos a soldar
los juntos al principio trate de torcer
juntos los extremos del led y la
resistencia pero son muy cortos y no
pude hacerlo lo que hice después fue
cortar otro pedazo de cable y tratar de
torcer lo con los extremos del led y la
resistencia pero tampoco funcionó
así que lo que terminé haciendo es usar
unas pinzas caimán para sostener la
resistencia y la pata del led aunque
como pueden ver me costó trabajo lograr
que se sostuvieran pero aunque cuesta un
poco de trabajo si usan las pinzas
caimán lo van a lograr las pinzas caimán
no solo nos ayudan a sujetar las piezas
sino que también absorben un poco del
calor de manera que no dañemos nuestros
leds ahora quitamos un poco del exceso
y haremos lo mismo con el otro led
en este momento usamos el tubo de
plástico que se encoge y vamos a pasarlo
por encima de la resistencia y así
proteger los cables expuestos de tocar
otras piezas de metal siempre debemos
asegurarnos de cubrir todos los cables
expuestos también pueden cubrirlos con
la cinta aislante negra cubrimos nuestra
conexión con el plástico que se encoge
aunque igual podemos usar la cinta
aislante
aunque el tubo nos dará un acabado más
prolijo cubrimos ambas resistencias y
todos hemos juntos los extremos sueltos
de ambas y estos a su vez los unimos
torciendo con el cable negro que va a
tierra en nuestro controlador del motor
o la salida negativa de nuestro
controlador del motor esto no es
sencillo de hacer y como acaban de ver
rompí la patita del led pues lo torcí
con mucha fuerza para arreglarlo voy a
tomar la resistencia y la voy a soldar
en lo que quedó de la patita del led
así ya quedó y espero que esto no le
suceda a ustedes
ahora si unimos y torcemos todo junto y
lo hicimos ya que tenemos estas piezas
unidas vamos a soldar las juntas para
asegurarnos que la unión sea sólida
los soldados bien y cortamos el exceso
y justo ahora me acabo de dar cuenta de
que el tubo plástico que puse en el
cable negro es muy estrecho como para
cubrir la soldadura nueva así que no
puedo usarlo como quería que era para
deslizarlo encima de la soldadura
tendría que haber usado un tubo de mayor
diámetro uso ahorita la pistola de calor
para encoger los tubos de plástico que
ya están colocados y ahora tomamos un
pedazo de cinta aislante negra para
cubrir esta parte que quedó descubierta
y aprovechamos que nos sirve para
mostrar que la cinta aislante también la
podemos usar para cubrir cables
expuestos cortamos el sobrante ahora que
ya tenemos conectados los leds y los
cables están aislados y conectados en
donde corresponde aunque les recomiendo
se aseguren de que los cables
efectivamente están bien conectados
ahora vamos a colocar las tapas de
plástico con agujero grande y aquí
debemos tener cuidado ya que hay que
empujar los leds a través de las tapas y
no queremos romperlos
una vez que ya tenemos puestas las tapas
nos aseguramos de que los leds siguen
conectados y que nada se ha desconectado
y ya que nos aseguramos de que todo
sigue funcionando bien podremos comenzar
a programarlo